This next story is sort of funny because it's
actually something that Donald Trump has stumbled
upon, threatening to do something that many
of us on the left would be very interested
in seeing him do. To some degree. Donald Trump is
now threatening to defund the entire military if
he's not allowed to punish the Internet for being
mean to him. This is the epitome of the triggered
snowflake child that is thin skinned Donald Trump.
So here's what happened back when Donald Trump
threw that bizarre temper tantrum last week on
Thanksgiving Day against a reporter where he said,
don't talk to me that way. This is the I'm the
president. You taught you respect me. The hashtag
diaper. Don started trending on Twitter. Trump was
furious about it and believed that Twitter should
be blocking the hashtag, stopping the hashtag,
whatever. So then Trump went on Twitter and said
that unless Section 230 is terminated as
part of the new funding of the military NDAA,
he will veto the entire defense funding bill.
Trump tweeted, quote, Section 230, which is a
liability shielding gift from the US to big tech
is a serious threat to our national security and
election integrity. Our country can never be safe
and secure if we allow that to stand. Therefore,
if the very dangerous and unfair Section 230 is
not completely terminated as part of the NDAA,
I will be forced to unequivocally veto the bill
when sent to the very beautiful resolute desk.
Take back America now. Thank you. So this
does require some explanation to understand
the connection, like what is the connection
between that and mean tweets about Trump?
And it really requires sort of stretching
your imagination to understand. Donald Trump
thinks that the reason Twitter allowed the
hashtag diaper, Don, to trend is that Twitter
is shielded from liability for the things on
its platform by Section 230. So the idea is
if you terminate section to 30, Twitter would then
be liable for the content on its platform rather
than the users being liable. And so Twitter would
say, oh, if we're liable, we're going to shut down
the diaper Don. Hashtag. But of course, this is
very, very stupid because first of all, why would
Twitter have liability? Because diaper, Don, is
trending like in other words, even if you repeal
Section two 30 and Twitter is now theorist's.
Liable for the content on their platform, what
is the liability with diaper Don trending like?
It's just a hashtag. Trump is a public person,
a very powerful public person. There are there
would be no repercussions for that. And secondly,
the hilarity is that if indeed Section two 30 was
terminated, Twitter would probably have to ban
Trump because it's Trump that regularly publishes
things to Twitter that would endanger Twitter.
Trump threat threatens people on Twitter.
Trump incites his followers to bully people,
as we've seen happen with Georgia election workers
over the last week or so. The incredible irony
is that Donald Trump seems to
think if Section two 30 goes away,
Twitter will block diaper done, but
more likely if Section two 30 goes away,
Twitter has to ban Trump. But then we get to the
really outrageous part, which is that Trump ran
on the biggest and best military ever, and he
claimed Obama ruined the military and Obama
hurt and diminished the military. And his
followers love the military. And on a whim,
Trump says if we don't make it so, Twitter will
block diaper done. I will defund the entire
military apparatus. And are his followers OK with
this? When some Democratic voters said defund the
police, they said, no, no, no, no, no, that'll
destroy America. Even even though no Democrats
in power want to defund, the police said almost no
Democrats in power want to defund the police. Now,
Trump, on a whim, says defund the military
because someone tweeted mean things about me.
And the cultists are mostly silent. There are a
few who are angry about it. And we will talk about
that on today's Bonas show. But the big takeaway
here is that January 20th cannot come soon enough.